hi guys
my girlfriend says that trans rights
activists make the distinction between
gender
what you choose and sex how you are born
she seems to think that you are
misinformed
any thoughts so many thoughts yeah
number one question is the girlfriend
the keeper
right that really dictates which
strategy you use in response to this
question i don't think it needs to
no no okay no i think you might as well
just go full truth on this one well
either way actually you'll find out if
she's a keeper i yes
okay so consider it some sort of a test
yeah um
yeah so gender
which is what uh we call in humans what
we would call sex role in
other species is basically the
behavioral manifestation of your sex
so yes there is a distinction but they
are tightly linked
and so it's all evolutionary and where
you draw the line between what is quote
unquote biological
and what is quote unquote social is
somewhat up to you um although we tend
not to talk in those terms because the
fact is it's all evolutionary
uh so uh the fact is that gender follows
from sex sex is binary
gender isn't gender is the manifestation
of your sex traditional gender roles
were much
closer to bimodal to to binary than they
are now
at this point your sex does not decide
nearly as many
things about what the options you have
in the universe are as they did even
even 50 years ago frankly but the idea
that
gender is simply a choice that is
independent of what your sex is
or independent of evolutionary process
is wrong and i would say one more thing
which is that not only is that true but
trans rights activists
as compared to actual trans people who
are mostly not in our experience on
board with the tra
ideology also pull a martin bailey and
so they say this
as if it's an argument which it's not
but even if it even if it were
um they will also then say actually even
sex isn't real
so um they have two arguments both of
which are wrong one of which is
more patently wrong than the other um
but even the sort of the weaker form of
the argument
which is that gender is a choice and sex
is
biological um isn't right
right so the tagline that i use
is gender is the software of sex
um and what that does suggest is that
gender is more flexible
it's varied it varies more between
cultures
it is not perfectly plastic but the
thing that was in the middle
of heather's excellent rant there was
that just the fact that something
is um cultural rather than genetic
does not mean that it isn't evolutionary
both of these things
are evolutionary they travel separately
through time so we have this
dual inheritance pattern and
gender is not perfectly free now can we
free it
if we want to at this moment in history
we can but
the idea that because it is not encoded
genetically
that it is somehow free from the uh
logical rules of the universe is just
nuts
yeah which is not an attack on anybody
and and you know
evergreen being what it was we had
numerous trans students many more than
we would likely have had
were we to teach somewhere else we had
very strong relationships with them
uh you traveled abroad uh with
uh trans students um so anyway it's
i think the thing is heather makes this
distinction between
trans people and trans rights activists
and
i can't say um what the overlap is but i
can say there are great many people
in the trans rights activist movement
who don't sound anything like the trans
people who
we knew who uh were wonderful i think
without exception that's right
and i guess i mean boy we we have
actually said
a fair bit about this i think i think
there's a rebel wisdom video of me
talking about this
and it's in a few places and it will con
we will continue to talk about this
for sure um but one more thing that i
will say that i have said before
uh is that if i were coming of age right
now um
as as the tomboy that i was um
people would probably be telling me that
i was trans and
that's simply it's offensive it's
regressive
it's disgusting not that being trans is
disgusting but the idea that i
as a girl who didn't didn't have
stereotypical gender norms who
far preferred dirt to dresses and
climbing trees to playing with dolls
was somehow therefore revealing my inner
inner truth as a boy no i never wanted
to be a boy i liked playing with boys
but it didn't have anything to do with
feeling like i wasn't a girl
nope just just abandoned many of the
traditional gender norms
so that was something that was true in
the 70s and 80s
which is now less true which means that
this is also the ideology in e way is
regressive
it's actually regressive it's actually
sexist and i would say misogynistic
yeah and actually you know you were the
first person that i heard
make this argument i've now heard
several other people make it including
katie herzog and i'm forgetting there's
a list of
three or four uh amazing women who have
now said something along these lines jk
rowling
actually said this um and so
what are we doing that we're tinkering
with something
that makes amazing women i mean it just
it's a it's a crazy thing to be messing
with um
and you know it is uh it is misogynistic
um and anyway it's got to stop yeah
i'm a lesbian and was told by several
very masculine trans women that i need
to quote get over my vagina fetish
this seems eerily similar to conversion
therapy to me and as someone who went
through conversion therapy as a youth
this concerns me
thoughts it should concern you it's
wrong it's it's simply wrong and
uh we all know what a lesbian is
and that's not it this is why the i
think this this is part of the evidence
the conflation of gender with sex
and actually you know so i have i know a
person i'm gonna
anonymize her somewhat uh
who is a lesbian and was in a
relationship for many years
and her partner transitioned and
um became unrecognizable to her
and uh she broke up with
the partner uh now identifying as a male
and is now with a new partner uh and the
thing that my
friend said to me about her new partner
with whom she's been for
several years now was not only did my
previous partner
change in personality at the point that
she was transitioning
but i also realized that the changes
physically
were unappealing to me and i've come to
understand something that i wouldn't
have allowed myself to think before
which is that i this friend of mine
actually really prefer very feminine
women you know that
that that's that's just the the
phenotype that i like
and i'm being made to think that this is
bigotry and the fact is like i've chose
this this woman i'm with now this love
of my life
is a very slight feminine woman and if
you had asked me 20 years ago i mean
this woman is a total badass and she's
she's
very um she's not butch but she's you
know she's very physically adept and
probably a tomboy herself in all of this
and she's saying i'm just i'm just not
gonna be ashamed of this anymore like
this is like this
i'm in love with this woman and it turns
out that this woman happens to have the
body type etc
that i am also attracted to and guess
what that's part of what being a lesbian
is
being like being attracted to women not
natal men who have declared it they're
women no matter how much other things
they've undergone
and not to say that some people who were
lesbians wouldn't follow trans men but
the whole thing is
ludicrous the whole thing is completely
ludicrous this falls in
douglas murray's category of things we
knew until yesterday
um that's a really good category it's a
really good category about that but i
mean
this is good how the [ __ ] is it that
some
man telling a woman that she needs to
get over her vagina fetish is not
sexual harassment or worse yes how is
that not obvious
how is this not obvious i mean frankly i
can't imagine if i was on the jury and
she had flat out hit this person
i think he'd asked for it if yeah if the
person writing the question
had flat out hit this these very
masculine trans women who are telling
you
you need to have sex you need to be
attracted to them and probably have sex
with them in order to demonstrate your
lack of transphobia
until yesterday in douglas murray's
schema
we knew that this was insane yeah we
knew that right and i think the correct
response might be something like
uh no it's not going to happen
but go back to argument school because
that isn't one